fancy going shopping stop no no no
whistling in the Burlington Arcade who
you we are the Burlington Beatles
probably the oldest and smallest police
force in the world you could say that we
police your manners right okay well mark
Lord had beetle of the bones in arcade
tell us your story
the beetle story start before we get
into that what actually is a beetle to
be honest with you I think anybody
really knows we predates any police
force in the country right back to the
story
go ahead mark the beetle story started
at this arcade okay and they games you
know so it's just like a shopping center
right yes okay third time lucky
go ahead mark the beetle story started
on the 28th of March 18 19
London was very different people didn't
really trust the water so they drank
even gin or beer and obviously that Lisa
was so startled behavior so the baby's
role really was to keep all the within
the arcade and in fact that tradition is
carried on right away fluid sorted by
our uniforms are made up of several
different layers we first of all put on
our waste gates there are four cows
announcer I pass in the summer or the
autumn in the winter you will still put
on your waistcoat
you will then put on your cape and your
sort of hands the original rule was here
were no whistling because the pig
pockets would whistle signals to one
another no drunkenness play a musical
instrument you're not supposed to Harry
some gentleman like an unladylike carry
your own parcels do you mustn't ring a
bicycle and accompanied ladies by the
way weren't all
allow them a lot of those rules we
couldn't enforce them we still try to
enforce it in their hurry in we still
try to enforce the low wisdom it's all
about behavior as long as you're
respecting those around you and
respecting the arcade you'll be left
alone and I'll put this uniform on I
represent nearly 200 years worth of
history makes me immensely proud yeah
once there's no attire if I'm one of you
that's actually true by the way isn't
just the you know the spill
[Music]